i pulled you over because you're a
murderer
yes i started to record because you
scared me and made me think you were
gonna murder me
okay well i'm sorry you feel that way
well you're that's not just a feeling
you're a murderer
okay and i'm perfectly legal
and i'm a teacher so there
congratulations
you're a murderer here you go mexican
racist
you're always going to be a mexican
you'll never be white you know that
right
you'll never be white which is what you
really want to be there you go
have a good day by now most of you have
seen that
shocking racist attack on an la county
sheriff's deputy who was simply just
doing his job
i should know the woman you saw hurl
those disgusting insults
claims to be a teacher if that's what
she says
in public imagine the poison she's
spewing
in class what's truly concerning though
is she's only the latest cop hater to
feel embolden enough to just abuse
and ridicule officers on the job la
county sheriff alex villanueva
says the frustration in his department
over hostile interactions
has hit alarming levels and sheriff
sheriff villanueva joins me now sheriff
this was this was stunning in a way
but sadly not to many of us who've been
covering these frankly racist attacks
and vicious attacks on police what is
the reaction in the
in the department
well one we're uh it's sad but it is
becoming all too common now and this is
a reality that our deputies face
on the streets and it's not so much the
people with the bullhorn screaming at
the top of their
lungs it's the politicians it's members
of the boards of supervisors
encouraging this behavior by trying to
pretend that somehow
uh that our department is full of people
that are actively harassing the public
when actually the opposite
as in this case shows very very well is
quite uh
common and that is the issue that we
have to confront and we just need people
to turn that volume down turn the anger
the bitterness down
let's just focus on interacting
respectfully with each other
now who's responsible here because a lot
of young people are being taught
a version of this at their university
classes or even
in school communications which i've
personally read
that we have to stop police brutality
against individu
of course no one wants police brutality
but the way it's written in schools
kids think all police are just smashing
people in the face or shooting them or
or abusing them in some way that's
what's horrible here sheriff and that's
what
she spewed at that um
that police officer
oh exactly and that is part of the big
lie that somehow
cops represent an existential threat to
young black men
and nothing can be further from the
truth and this the statistics show
this hard facts on the ground show it
unlawful murder for example like derek
chavin against george floyd those are
very rare extremely rare
in fact rarer than being struck by
lightning but yet you'll have
politicians and you'll have people
supposedly describing themselves as
leaders in the community
trying to tell people that they are
afraid in the presence of cops as
somehow we're an existential threat
and we're exact opposite of that we're
people that actually secure peace
provide that safety for the community
and sometimes at the expense of our own
lives
well the attorney general of the united
states
sheriff testified today on capitol hill
and he has some new idea about how to
spend money on police departments
promoting public trust between
communities and law enforcement
is an essential to making both
communities
and policing safer our budget proposes
increased investment in programs that
support community oriented policing
and addressing systemic inequities
including 1.2 billion
an increase of 304 million
systemic inequities i know you already
have a very diverse workforce
in la but it seems that the real message
is
you need to root out the extremists on
the force and address the systemic
racism
well i can tell you that my the
population the county jail
right now mirrors exactly the population
of suspects who commit violent crime
murder rape robbery assault with a
deadly weapon
it is a one-on-one correlation between
the suspects and those crimes
and the population of those are detained
in the county jail awaiting trial
so anybody claims there's some kind of
systemic inequity
in that well they're not seeing the
truth is right in front of them
violence fills the jails not some type
of
systemic racism or some kind of scheme
for mass incarceration
it's just not there it's plain old
violence we need to put an end to it
and speaking of some of the politicians
inflaming the situation
here's what congresswoman elon omar said
last night on msnbc
it is important for there to be a
federal
oversight board that does proactive
investigations every single time that
there is a life lost
in the custody of police officers every
single time that there is
bodily harm caused by the police
sheriff your response to a constant
presence of a federal oversight
board that is absolute nonsense one the
the sure ability to do a successful
investigation
i'm sorry but people outside of the fbi
in their limited resources to do
investigations
the experts are going to be local law
enforcement doing these investigations
and they're driven by evidence by facts
the overwhelming majority
of people who die as a result of an
officer-involved shooting
died because of the actions they take
that threatens the life of either the
cop
or somebody else and as a result of the
intervention of the cop
they lose their life but it is driven by
their actions
and people refuse to acknowledge that in
fact later on they'll cite the evidence
from previous years and say
they were all murders and forget that
the guy came out of the bank guns
blazing
and dies in a hail of bullets exchanging
it with law enforcement
sheriff really quickly that's the grim
reality what's the percentage chance
if you're pulled over by a police
officer if you do not
resist that what the police officer is
asking you to do lawfully
of you having any harm come to you
what's the percentage chance
about zero uh every single person who
ends up in trouble
in some way resist police or someone
who's with them
shoots at the police so i mean
it's horrible when anyone dies i don't
want anyone to die but don't resist the
police
when they're getting pulled over sheriff
thank you for coming on tonight that
video was disgusting thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else